this is
a a great day we're talking about we're
having our second
lecture on glass and we've got a demo
where did peter go okay so we've got a
demo uh
uh coming up for you from the director
of the glassblowing lab here at mit
um uh and uh now before we start i just
wanna mention
so uh next monday so we're gonna talk
today we're going to
continue what we started which is the
chemistry of glass
and we'll talk about that cooling curve
right
or the effects of of different things on
the glass
formation and then how to engineer the
properties of the glass
before i start i just want to mention
that on next monday
uh we have something called the wolfe
lecture and
um this is a lecture that is open to the
public
it's geared towards freshmen it's put on
by the department of materials science
and engineering
every year and it's it's usually some
sort of really interesting exciting
topic and usually a very dynamic
lecture and in this case it's one of our
very own sam shames who graduated in
2014
um and he'll he'll be talking about
his adventures uh as a material
scientist
and and how he's used that knowledge
in his life um and also in the company
that he founded which is now selling
products in over 70 countries
uh around the world so um so
uh i think that'll be a lot of fun if
you can make it it's next monday
uh from four to five p.m
okay now the second uh point i want to
make
is uh that so uh there's a mistake on
tomorrow's quiz so quiz
in in the in the schedule no just in the
schedule so quiz
eight quiz number eight will be given at
the beginning of class
quiz eight is
at beginning of class
um not the end i think it might
mistakenly say the end
and and uh so you might notice there's
been a little bit of you know sometimes
the quiz is
is you know so tomorrow the quiz is
going to cover defects
uh right and then what was
uh whatever was covered up until you
know monday's lecture
and tuesday's recitation which includes
the beginning of what we talked about
okay let's let's not do that let's turn
that off
okay and um and and part of the you know
we had an exam on a monday and so we
didn't want to give you a quiz that week
and then
uh you know so so that's why things have
something you know so we're doing
defects tomorrow even though we covered
defects last week
um and and then we didn't we didn't
really want to
you know we didn't want to give you a
quiz right before or
on thanksgiving that didn't seem right
uh so for the next quiz
um uh what we're doing is we're still
making a quiz for you to have but
and we're going to give it to you next
week but we're not going to count it
okay
so next week you will still get a quiz
that you have for your studying
uh and just to sort of you know because
i know you'll miss it
um but in case you're not here
or you don't want to do the quiz over
your turkey
we're not going to count that one so
quiz 9 won't be counted
okay all right so that's the quizzes
oh now where were we
here we are you know speaking of quiz
material and
uh potential like thinking about glass
as a potential problem on tomorrow's
quiz uh
yes uh you might want to know about some
of the things we talked about monday
here's like an example okay
here's a question uh i have two glasses
they form from liquids and they're
cooled to some temperature i call t1
and i tell you that t1 is greater than
tm which is the melting point
of the material now remember the melting
point
is the same it's a number the melting
point of silica
right that's a number but when
the material forms a glass can vary
why does a glass form well a glass
forms uh this is what we covered on
money it can form because of
of sort of three different things right
one
is the crystal complexity
that's important another
is the viscosity
and the third is the cooling rate
those are those are the three things
that we covered our money
for on monday for reasons why
a glass might form and then we started
kind of talking about the cooling rate
that's what we need to understand to
answer this question
right so okay two glasses forming
liquids are cooked
one glass is formed plot the molar
volume versus temperature
all right so now okay let's see how
about this
could this be the volume per mole
versus temperature so i'm going to try
it out here i'm going to go like this
i'm going to go like this and
that looks like the liquid maybe okay
and then i'm going to go like this
and maybe this and
we'll call that t1 does that look right
no this can't be right
this can't be right because you see i
said that t1
this this is a glass transition
that's a glass transition that's a tg
that's another tg but i've said in the
question
t1 is greater than tm
t1 is greater than tm well so this can't
be true
because t tm has to be out here
tm is out here where there's a different
transition that occurs
and it turns into a crystal right so
this could this couldn't be right
t one greater than tm
okay so what about another one let's try
another one
so how about if i okay volume per mole
now i'm gonna go like this okay so i'm
gonna go
like this and
uh okay so now here comes one
and here comes the other
okay and you know
okay so and i'm gonna put now uh t1
maybe
let's try it t1 is going to be out here
and tm uh would be
actually let me let me do it differently
sorry i'm going to go like this
i'll just connect
how do i want to do this i wanted to
join these up there
yeah that's a good that's another good
mistake i'm
making mistakes on purpose
on purpose and let's make t1 be out here
okay so t1 is here and then tm could
still be
there this could be tm and then maybe
is that right is that a possible curve
well i i've fixed the t1 tn problem
because t1 is now greater than
than tm like i said in the question but
what is going on here
what is going on you say well but i
cooled one
faster than the other isn't that kind of
what's happening here and maybe i
started changing the curve
you know i start no that's not what this
is
so don't make that mistake this you see
remember
the slope the slope
is equal to the thermal expansion
coefficient
right thermal expansion
coefficient and those slopes are the
same for the different glasses just
because i've cooled one
differently that's not they're not going
to have different slopes and this is the
fundamental
challenge that this is the fundamental
confusion point that happens
which is that this is not time this
axis is not time
so what we're doing so this is wrong too
what we're doing is we're talking about
something involving
time cooling rate okay but we're
plotting it
on something that doesn't involve time
and that can lead to confusion so i
wanted to point that out
you say well shouldn't the slope be
different because you're cooling it
slower or faster no that's not what this
slope is this slope is a thermal
expansion coefficient
so the right answer to this must be
that you have your
nice liquid phase and you've made your
two glasses
okay so here's one this was cooled
this is cooled faster
this is slower right
this would be tg this would be another
tg
right maybe tg1 tg2 and
the tm would come down
and have you know okay well i've run out
of room here
but tm might come down like this
and so t1 must be somewhere up here
right okay that would be a correct plot
for that question basically i just want
you to get a feeling for this plot
right we introduced it monday and i
really want you to feel
your oneness with this plot because it's
a very important plot to understand
why glasses form okay all right now
moving on there's
a lot of properties of of glasses and
here i'm talking about oxide glasses so
silica right remember
silicon oxide oxide silica
right alumina but these are you know uh
oxide okay we talked about that
chemically inert electrically insulating
mechanically brittle
optically transparent visually arresting
i like that one these are the properties
that we know
about about these kinds of glasses we
already know them but what i want to
talk about today is how they can be
engineered and and
this plot this plot is a basis for
understanding that
and so is spaghetti and that's what
we're going to talk about
but so so the very first one which will
set up our demo in just a few minutes
the very first one that i want to talk
about is the mechanical properties we
know glass to be very brittle
right but could we change its mechanical
properties could we do something
about the mechanical properties and by
the way if those are the things that
that dictate whether a glass forms or
not
then those are the things that you might
think we might try to engineer
if we want to change the properties of
glass
all right you can imagine i'm a silica i
got to pass this out
i'm a big silicate an sio4
and i'm connected to these other
silicate groups through this shared
bridged oxygen
right and it's i'm a
bulky thing and i'm trying to move
around in the liquid
right crystal complexity i'm cooling
down
and i'm trying to move around and
waze told me to go that way but it's
actually over there there's no building
there and i don't know where to go where
is the lattice site
it's complicated glass could form
glass could form or maybe i'm a silicate
group and i'm like
hey could you please get out of my way
you're really slowing things down
you other silicate group that i'm
attached to
viscous get out of my way no i can't
viscous or or maybe you're a silicate
group and you're cooling down and you're
like
that was that was very sudden
i didn't even realize that happened all
of a sudden i'm supposed to be a solid
right this is what's happening and so
instead of getting into this beautiful
quartz crystal it doesn't get there
it doesn't get there a super cold liquid
wants to be a solid
it wants to but it can't
for some reason for some reason that is
one of that has to do with those right
so let's just
have this in our hands while we're
listening and thinking about things
and let me just tell you about this one
very one way
let's you know if i take a piece of
glass if i take a piece of glass
and now imagine that i take some part of
it
like this part here okay
and and in this part i'm gonna cool
faster in this part here
i'm going to cool
slower so it's imagine it's a slab of
glass and it's like the edges
the edges are cooled at a different rate
okay
that's actually exactly why a car window
if you look at it through polarized
glasses has spots on it those spots some
of you may have seen these
those spots are changes purposeful
changes in the mechanical properties of
the glass to keep you safe
why this if you cool it
slower then you might have some volume
that you want right the volume here
let's call this v b
and let's call this v a that goes along
with the graph we used before b
and a right so
so it wants the
uh what did i do b this wants v
a yeah but look what happens if
if i make a piece if i purposely cool
the top
really fast or maybe i make spots that i
cool fast
right then what happens well this this
wants to have
volume a uh inside this wants to have on
well
this cools first right
so this cools first so so inside
so what happens as i cool it now
i have this
this is now a glass
this is now a solid i should say
you know glass uh solid okay so it's
solidified
and this wants
to have a lower volume lower
volume it wants a lower volume but
that's been frozen
at a higher volume why i cooled it
faster
that's it i cooled it faster and now the
inside is like wait a second
i'm not cooling so fast i don't need
such a high volume
can i please get a smaller volume out of
this and the top is like well i'm
already stuck
i'm already a solid and what happens is
it pulls
and so you get you get what you get
is once lower volume
pulls on the surface
and that means that this is going to be
the top if i'll just draw it one more
time
will be under compression
under compression and the inside
will be under tensile stress
you can kind of under tensile stress you
can kind of imagine this right you can
see it
i i'm frozen the top because of cooling
rate it's right here
i just cool the top faster the inside
isn't cold yet
it starts to cool and it it tries to
solidify at a different volume it pulls
it in
but see that changes the mechanical
properties
of the surface that's called tempering
that's called tempered glass this is
tempered glass
and there is no better example of
tempered glass
than the prince rupert's drop which is
the demo that peter has come now peter
here's peter there's peter
blowing some glass is what he does you
know in in his free time he just
throws these big glass bowling parties
he also happens to be
the director of the glass lab like i
said he also teaches
the classes the glassblowing classes
there's one for freshmen during iep
and there's another one in the spring
they're very popular but because you're
in 309
one he'll get you in he doesn't like it
when i say that
it's because it's not true
but but come talk to him
he's right here and and i think you got
a demo for us right
so so i'm going to let peter take the
stage and show you
the best example of tempered glass you
can do
and and if you want to use the mic
if you want to talk kit out
one year professor sema when he was
teaching this class
told the class that they had to come to
the lottery for the glassblowing club
and it's a big it's a big class and so
dutifully
everyone came to the lottery we already
have about 150 students
plus 3091 and the lottery was in room
6120
so we overflowed
by a lot so i told michael don't ever do
that again please
which is why i do it every year um but
we like 309 students we'll try to give
them preference
[Music]
he says that
so get out the secret weapon here
how many of you have seen through
conduction for
some people yeah there's a lot of online
stuff about them
but you get to see a live one today
so what's the difference between a
prince rupert drop and
tempered glass like the jeff just heard
it
anybody want to take a guess at that
[Music]
they're both under stress but the stress
is generated in different ways
so the dots that were on that windshield
are formed by air cooling
that's how tempered glass is made it
goes through what's called a leer
or a rolling conveyor and it's heated up
very very quickly and then it's cooled
very quickly
and it's cooled by this array of
compressed air jets on both sides
that take it from almost the transition
temperature from
it's just about wants to move but it
doesn't fight down to room temperature
in three minutes or so and that rapid
super rapid cooling is what generates
that
that stress on the the difference
between the inside and the outside
temperature and the glass
and so it's air cooled but a prince
rupert drop is
cooled by anyone that we get
water yeah by water so water is a better
coolant right
so as a result you get a lot more stress
embodied in the glass a lot more stress
and so that's relevant because
i mean you don't want to make a window
that breaks with that kind of energy
so you get explosive energy all over the
place
so tempered glass is engineered to fail
it's it's
very strong but it's underneath
engineered to fail so when it breaks it
breaks into small pieces
so that if you're walking along the
sidewalk and the skyscraper blows out a
window
you don't get huge shards of glass
falling down and
hurting people you get little pellets
gently raining down which isn't such a
bad thing
so i've got two kinds of french grouper
drops that i made here and uh
and a vessel in which to demonstrate
here
so first i'm going to show you they're
both cool
rather quickly the one was cooled in air
one's cooled in water
this is the one that's cooled in air
so what i'm going to do by the way i
used to give a demo in the glass lab
where
i would take the prince group or drop
put it on a steel table that we call the
marver
and hit it with a hammer as hard as i
could i was never able to shatter
this head with a hammer in fact i dented
the marbler so many times that i stopped
doing that demo
so i have a different way of doing it
now which is
i won't do that today but usually i'll
have a student come and try to break the
princebook or drop in their hands
it's really hard to do most people can't
do it but
the air-cooled prince rupert drop
doesn't have the same kind of strength
so watch what happens
[Music]
well let's try down farther maybe
there's more stress there
nope not really
should we try one more time maybe where
it's thicker
maybe there'll be more stress
maybe a little
so here's the one that's water cooled
okay don't blink
five four three
two one
so that that's the speed of sound
in glass which is i think about three
times faster than the speed of sound
in air so you can't see it but there's
some great high-speed video
maybe some of you have seen that online
of prince rupert drops exploding
and actually up in the androgen center
they have a camera that can
catch that and we've got some really
cool video i'm going to leave this
this is a very cool fragment that shows
the fracture
the failure pattern which is really
interesting it fails from the center
of the drop radially out at an angle
that looks to be about 45 degrees
you can probably explain that that'll be
on the quiz tomorrow
[Music]
is there a question i'm going to do one
more just in case anybody blinked
and then
by the way jeff mentioned that we have
an iep class
that starts during iep for freshmen
and a spring class that's open to
everybody at the institute so if you're
not a freshman
you can come to the lottery the
lotteries for all of our classes
are shown on the glass lab website and i
think we're going to be doing the
lottery for the spring
for the iap class in november late this
month
and then the spring pass will probably
be
sometime in january and it starts in
march okay ready
five four three two
one that was a bigger one
[Music]
thanks peter
that was that was awesome and i actually
do have a high speed video of it so i'll
show that to you now
um and and again um if you know so if
you have questions about glass
if you want to watch peter can make like
animals for you
i think on request
uh but anyway thanks a lot peter for
coming by um
and and you know there's nothing like as
you know i'm
i'm a big believer in in hands-on seeing
things
and um can we pass is this no that's
well i don't want pure call okay yeah
okay
so so now you know on
on on parents day right when we have
parents here
we have the two sheets of glass one is
called annealed it's it just means it's
not tempered
and and the baseball was supposed to
break it
it didn't peter's got very good in the
old glass he's the one that gave us
those big sheets
and it breaks into these huge dangerous
shards whereas if you notice thanks
peter take care
if you notice um oh yeah let's thank you
if you notice when i the the tempered
glass
we tried to break it it also doesn't
break
it was supposed to be the only one that
didn't break um but then you take a
little hammer at the edge
and you just you just lightly tap the
edge and the whole thing breaks why
because it's got so much built-in stress
it's got all this compressive stress and
the edge
isn't protecting that the edge of that
tempered glass
isn't protecting the stress so when i
just dig it a little bit
it's able to all crack and release that
stress right
so that's what happened on family day
here's a high speed video
these are two guys from corning and
we can listen to this they're actually
pretty cool so there's a few things
going on here
the cold water rapidly cools the
exterior surface of the glass
hardening it almost immediately the
interior
still molten cools more slowly as it
cools it contracts and attempts to pull
the surface in with it
but it can't well not very much the
surface has already hardened so it gets
pulled in only a little
compressing it while also creating an
internal layer that remains
forever under tension it is this action
that gives the glass its
uncharacteristic strength
we call it compressive strength
it sounds like the same principle is how
an arch provides strength in
structural engineering yes kind of now
jamie i'm going to ask for your help
we're going to attempt to destroy this
prince rupert drop
i just want you to tip that hammer past
its center point
go ahead
that's what peter was talking about so
you can hit it really hard
i feel like we've been swindled swindled
not we have just experienced
power of fighting it does however have
an achilles heel take
those nippers right there and nip
the back side of the tail of this prince
rupert drop and watch what happens wait
wait cue the high speed camera
okay here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was even cooler than i thought it
would be
so that's that's what you just saw live
and and what that is
is it's a relief of thank you
why not yeah sure
what you saw you know as peter said
tempered glass like in your car it's
done with air cooling
right that's literally what those
circles are
if you cool it even faster
bam faster cooling you now know
what does faster cooling mean well if
it's to form a glass
you might be all the way near the
melting point
and you're going to have an even higher
volume per mole which is going to cause
even more stress within the glass which
is going to make
the surface very strong right because
it's all compressed
but it's also going to have a lot of
energy in it that it wants to release
okay okay now but let's see
we were here on monday and because i was
talking about
other ways to change the properties in
fashion remember i showed you a couple
of different examples of glass right a
glass cup and and a glass bottle
and and it turns out there's not just
silica
in it there's all these other things in
it and and there's
many many kinds of glass and i listed a
few here this was from monday so i'm
showing it again
and going all the way back to glass made
in ancient rome you'll find
that it's got these other ingredients
why so that's what i want to talk about
next right
so um oh let's use this so
um if you notice
and this is where we left off monday if
you notice something like
uh calcium oxide well it's going to go
to ca2 plus
and o two minus so okay let's look at
na2o na2o is going to go to two
n a plus plus o two minus
uh how about alumina that's on there al2
well that's going to go to 2 a l
3 plus plus 3
o 2 minus notice a pattern
the pattern is you get o2 minus
o 2 minus and we know
we can understand why o2 minus has been
used
why chemistry has been used
to change the properties of glass for
millennia
and and the reason goes back to the
pictures that we drew on monday where we
started
by talking about the chemistry of the
silicate group right
and so remember you know s i remember
this
right like an s i o four
is happy if it's got four minus charges
remember that okay and it saw we started
with lewis and it satisfies the octet
but then in glass what happens is you
bridge
and so you have this and i won't draw
all of them i'll just draw it the way we
drew it before
okay and you have these bridges and all
of the oxygens
are are bridges in glass
right uh but so now say well what if i
wanted
to remember these are these are forming
these long viscous
chains what if i wanted to make them
flow
a little more easily what if i wanted
them to form
shorter chains what if i wanted to
cut the pasta don't do it in italy
they'll get really upset but americans
are okay with it
if you need to cut the pasta it's okay
in this country
okay if i need to cut the pasta in
chemistry and it's glass
that i'm cutting o2 minus is my knife
it's my chemical scissors chemical
scissors i like that
chemical scissors
why well you can see because i go back
what did the oxygen do it
it by bridging it didn't need that extra
electron
but if i bring now something like na2
you know na2o so i've got an o2 minus
now i'm going to add
add an o2 minus
then what'll happen is you're going to
cut this
right so now i'll just draw the
i'll see if i can okay so now i've
added not just an oxygen atom but the
two
charges that each of them needed before
they bridged
you see to be happy right and so now
this can have one of those charges
and over here you can have another one
and so on okay and so on
let's see now i've cut i've
cut the glass pasta
and i've done it chemically and i've
done it from understanding of octet and
lewis from basic chemistry principles
that we've learned
whereas the sodium go well they're you
know they'll be like a sodium it'll want
to hang out close
by these right there'll be these ions in
there these sodium ions will be in there
still right
if it was you know if it was na2o if
it's something else and it's a different
kind of ion that might be left over
but the main thing is i've delivered the
chemistry needed
to cut this and this is called chain
incision there's a term for it
chain precision
the technical term for cutting glass
pasta
well this is powerful and this is very
powerful because
if i can cut this these those are the
silicate groups
right and and if i can cut them then i
can change
another property look i can change the
viscosity
i've hit another one of those three
reasons why glass forms
right um and and so
i'll show you a slide in a minute to
show you the change in the viscosity but
just to give you a sense
of what can happen how does that
impact right how does that impact well
for silica
crystal the transition the melting point
is greater than 1200 c
okay for tg of soda
lime glass
it's 500c
so you can imagine now
i've got another mechanism i've got
another way not just processing
not just cooling rate but chemistry
to mess with this curve right because
you can imagine now that i might be able
to get
to a lower and lower transition points
right you see this
i might be able to get to lower and
lower transition points if these things
can move
faster and not get locked in to a solid
as easily if i add more and more of
these
chemical scissors right and so
so maybe this this one now instead of
being cooled slower
maybe this one had more soda
right than this one maybe now they're
cooled at the same rate
but i've changed the the amount of
impurities that are the amount of oxygen
o2 minus very specifically
that i've put in right so it's another
way now
to change this uh this curve okay
now these are called
you know the the thing that forms the
glass and we're really only talking
about silica as our glass you can make
other types of glass not made from
silica we're talking about silicon in
this class so
silicon is the atom that is making those
long spaghetti strands and it's called
the network former
silicon is called the network former and
then
the thing that i put in there the thing
that i put in there that modified the
network
is called the network modifier so you
can see on this graph
that you got your you know what you've
got is your bridging
you know the the bridging there uh
that's going between two network formers
and and then you've got these these
atoms
that are hanging out near a place where
you've broken a bridge
so those would be modifiers those are
called network modifiers these are just
terms
that you will hear and see when you
think about glass network formers
network modifiers
the chemistry that you introduce is
modifying the network and it's what
is done in many many different ways with
many many different dopants
to change the properties of glass okay
and so here's here's the curve that
shows you
another kind of important way of looking
at this
and i don't need you to remember all
these terms but i want to show you
because this is how glass is engineered
remember today i want to talk about you
know this the topic is how do we change
the properties
so talk about cooling rate now we're
talking about adding chemicals
um notice and so now when you're you're
going to work with the glass to do
something with it
if you're going to do that this is one
of the first plots you'll look up
right and it shows you it plots the
temperature this
really doesn't work at all the
temperature on one axis so that's like
the x-axis
and on the y-axis is the viscosity
because now that's the property that
we're changing right the viscosity
and notice that when i at okay so
there's silica
up in the upper right you see that so
fused silica that's basically
almost quartz that's basically quartz
right so you are really close to making
a nice crystal
right but notice how high
a viscosity you have versus temperature
notice that you're at this
very very high value for viscosity it's
a really thick material
and and people care a lot about
viscosity when they work with glass why
because
you need to know for example is it is it
at a point
you know is the viscosity a point where
i can work with it can i shape it
that's the bottom right that's the
region that says working range
i can still shape it i can make a window
right
uh okay there it flows under its own
weight
so now i could shape it and it'll lose
the shape
that's kind of important to know like if
i'm making like a glass animal
okay uh oh there it's um it
its stress can still be relieved
remaining stress can still be relieved
and up there
you can rapidly cool it without
introducing new defects right but look
at the
the trade-off between the temperature
that you have to go to
and the viscosity and the viscosity that
you have
so if you go now from the this almost
quartz all the way down okay there's you
take a little bit of stuff and you put
it in but it's still 96 silica and now
you go to borosilicate
remember it's like 75 80 silica
plus you know other additives and look
at how much you've changed
the temperature so i can now work with
this material below a thousand c
that has huge consequences for
industry right for actually making uh
different things out of glass which we
now do regularly
but but and the romans did it too but
they didn't know why
they said well you have a little bit of
this dirt something different happens
let's try a little bit of that one
right now we know we know why
and and you know the and so so this
curve now is something that we
understand and we understand how to
control it
and if you go back to the um
the example of making glass tough
you know i was just showing you these
ions right these these sodium ions
they're left in there well it turns out
that you can put
ions into glass and maybe you're doing
it to change the viscosity
so the thing stays liquid for longer and
you can maybe work with it in in
different regimes
but maybe you're putting the ions in
there to do something else
right uh and and so actually
there's a whole nother thing you can do
once you have ions in the glass like
sodium
you can substitute them out right
imagine that i have that's what this
picture this next picture is showing
imagine okay that i've got a glass in
here
and those red circles are sodium
but now i've introduced a different ion
on the surface
that's potassium what happens well if i
have a high concentration
of potassium and i put it on a surface
of glass that has a bunch of sodium
in it so now i've got a glass with
sodium ions
in it and
i expose it to a potassium bath
so now i've got potassium right up here
and what happens is if the concentration
is high enough and the conditions are
right
i can get potassium to go in for the
sodium
right and so actually now i can
substitute
so these these were here i can now
substitute those
for potassium
well this is a big deal because
potassium is bigger than sodium
and and so if i if i am able to on the
surface let's say
put put something bigger in there then
you can imagine that it's pushing
the other stuff into each other that's
causing the same
stress k plus
bigger
than sodium and this causes
this huge surface tension
same principle as tempering
but now i've done it chemically this
is gorilla glass this is all phone
screens
this is what they do right because you
can get
really really hard glass this way and
and if you go back to these guys
they have a little this is just a very
short video they've got this sort of
longer videos on the corning website
that talk about this they shoot bullets
through gorilla glass
you can make glass really strong with
just chemical substitutions
and all you're thinking about is atom
size because by putting this
larger atom in you cause the same kind
of compressive stress at the surface
find over time but like all gorilla
glass variants that came before it
it is compressive strength glass but
it's not made in the same way as we just
demonstrated the rapid cooling method no
instead
corning uses an ion exchange process to
break it down simply
the surface ion particles that naturally
form during the manufacture are replaced
with
larger ion particles once exchanged the
larger ion particles create the same
sort of inward pressure
that we see on the prince rupert drop
and with this method they are able to
control
and manage the resulting
the resulting what what was he gonna say
i don't know actually i don't remember i
have to go watch it now
uh so that's that's just a video showing
you what i just showed you which is that
that's yet another way
of engineering the properties of glass
and there are so
many more and and this is really you
know what
one of the points i want to make today
about how to engineer glass so we're
talking about how to
change this curve maybe we change the
viscosity by adding o2
which changes you know the curve here
maybe we change the cooling rate
right um uh uh
maybe i can use additives uh ions in
different ways but it turns out that
we have come to a place where we can
engineer every single one of these
properties
we can make conducting glass even though
it's usually been
and usually is insulating we can make
chemically active glass
right as you just saw we can change the
mechanical
properties there are now flexible rolls
of glass
that look literally like saran wrap
almost but they're glass
right um and and so it all comes down to
the pasta and so
where we are if we use the pasta analogy
which as you
i think can understand i really like
because i really like pasta
this is a great analogy for glass
because it's like
you know in in the in the roman time all
we had was one sauce
everything just mix it all in meatballs
pesto
red sauce carbonara i could go on
and that's all they did they just didn't
know why things were happening but now
that we know about the electronic
structure of atoms
we can make glass into any delicious
pasta dish we want
right okay don't eat it but you know
what i mean
and so i'll give you a couple of
examples so the point is
the last 20 centuries we're really just
getting warmed up when it comes to this
material
and and what it's led to are
you know what the recent understanding
of how to engineer
this material has led to our real
breakthrough ideas
and so i'll show you just a couple um in
my why this matters
because you know glass is after all made
of there it is up there in case you can
see it this is the
abundance of elements versus atomic
number
and you notice the very top two elements
are silicon and oxygen
right and and and so it'd be really nice
if we could make a lot of stuff out of
these really abundant cheap elements
think sand
right could i take sand and make a lot
of stuff out of it
well not if i can't control it not if i
have to heat it up to 3000 degrees
or its viscosity isn't what i want or it
doesn't give me the properties i want
but that has
changed that has fundamentally changed
so we can now look at materials like
this these super abundant materials and
we can completely rethink them and i'll
give you one example
it's our it's already a few years old
but i think it's just a really cool
uh idea which is called the solar center
and and here he's he's developed this
machine that
is entirely solar powered the solar
cells for the electricity
and it's a focused uh beam of light from
the sun
that gets hot enough to engineer the
glass so he takes sand
from the desert that he's in he puts it
in a container
and he's got a 3d printer that he's made
it's entirely solar-powered
there's no fossil fuels but he can take
sand
and turn it into something structural
right and so there's a vase that he's
made and you can take that out
and and again that's just the beginning
of rethinking what we could do with
these super abundant materials
here's an example from also a few years
ago from an mit lab
um this is neri oxman's lab and she's in
the mediated matter lab
at uh here at mit and she's developed a
3d printer
and so there it is printing uh something
with glass right and she can print lots
of different designs now
using glass he has a cool video
um and there's the print head
and again
1900 fahrenheit
so
there's the printer
i'm not sure that i want a 1900
fahrenheit printer on my desktop
um but as you can imagine you know
what what they had to do i'll just give
you one more example and then a little
stop
what they had to do was understand
everything we've just talked about how
do you engineer the viscosity the
melting point
to make it all work in a 3d printer the
last point i'll give you
is this i love this this is from a few
years ago it's a group in japan
that made a glass that is as strong as
steel
and what they talk about this is what i
like they say just think of a world
where your smartphone wouldn't shatter
okay
cool buildings could be bolstered
against natural disasters
even cooler and then somehow they bring
it down wine glasses are reassuringly
safe
was that really a problem i i don't know
and what they did fabrication was
conducted using an
aerodynamic levitation furnace where
ingredients were floated in the air
using oxygen gas and melted together
using co2 lasers
and they get a transparent super glass
of 50 alumina
that was so hard to do because the
aluminum
didn't want to be a glass it wanted to
go and become
a metal a structural a crystal but by
doing it this way they were able to
capture it in the disorder
okay all right have a great night see
you guys on friday
you